I heard this Ferris guy apparently he
was talking about me as well yeah you
are the last person to speak to you what
service have you done to the ummah
except blame the Palestinians for what
they are going through
[Music]
um
I mean we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah
this video I've been well I already done
it on another channel uh but I thought
I'm so passionate about what's happened
pertaining to about Eamon but I want to
do this video by not mentioning another
person's name who uh sadly has kind of
mocked him uh another individual
actually I think there's two of them if
I'm not mistaken
um one of them just you know those who
know who know you know and I'm going to
go into context inshallah brother aiming
is somebody that I came to know about
good seven eight years ago done a video
with him pretending to marrying single
mothers uh devotee of single mothers for
that matter
um we did this video a long long time
ago very good brother I haven't seen
anything bad in him alhamdulillah he is
someone that appeals to a certain um
group of brothers he's come from that uh
jahilia of being on the roads Etc he
himself was stabbed I know his story
I've seen videos of himself when he was
kidnapped he showed it to us it was
disturbing to me you know subhanallah so
I've heard that many of the stories and
some somebody who's doing a great
service to the Omar from what I can see
with the videos Etc on Tick Tock in
general uh actually alhamdulillah and I
recently a couple of weeks ago I spoke
to him as well
um
and I actually tried to call him uh a
week ago because I realized a lot of
people giving him hate online for
something that he did which we all go
through I'm the largest to speak to him
and to tell him how I deal with it Etc
uh but inshallah that'll be for another
day but today's video was basically
about him now should you listen to him
now brothers and sisters like I said
very clearly there are some people who
are criticizing him why because he
speaks like a road man yeah now this is
somebody who is from that life he was
from that lifestyle he's not glorifying
it he might come across like that but
not really like in my marriage
documentary I talk about majahilia in a
different aspect when it came to
relationships and Haram relations that I
was indulging Etc he might come across
that as if I'm
in like glorifying or something like
that but no actually there's deeper
rooted problems so I can relate with
them in that sense where he is talking
in that not talking in that way that's
how he talks yes and that's how he's
been brought up so the thing is to
attack him from the way he's talking to
me it's crazy because he does so much
good work like the guy is bringing
hundreds if not thousands of people who
are on the roads who might be carrying a
knife who might be carrying knuckle
dusters you might be carrying guns or
whatever for that matter they could have
done an armed robbery that day they
could have gone and stabbed somebody
they could have taken somebody's life
they could have been doing all kinds of
stuff the massages are flocked literally
hundreds if not thousands literally
outside on the streets listening to him
now how could I someone in the dawa
field or in the public sphere whatever
it may be for that matter look at that
and be like hmm what can I pick on let
me see what's going to pick on let me
see I genuinely right now I don't even
know what to pick on there's nothing to
pick on I would have to go out of my way
spend a whole day get a whiteboard do
some brainstorming have I need to have
some kind of a disease in my heart or
something that I have to be like what
can I pick on oh I know let me pick on
him speaking like a road man
yeah so why would I go and say oh you
know why do you have to mention your
story why'd you have to speak like this
yeah okay
Allah says in the Quran the one who
saves one soul is as if you save the
whole of humanity the one who kills one
soul is as if he's killed of all of
humanity the guy God knows how many
people's lives he's saving with the
permission of Allah by bringing these
Road guys to the massage it that they
never ever would think of going to how
many lives probably that guy saved on
that day alone let alone how many people
did he change in a massage with his
thoughts that probably would have killed
God knows how many people
and we are here talking about the most
petty stuff I heard this Ferris guy
apparently he was talking about Miss
World yeah you are the last person to
speak what service have you done to the
ummah except blame the Palestinians for
what they are going through
able to do there's no betrayal we're
supporting Palestinians all the way the
Betrayal is happening from the
Palestinians himself actually
when have you criticized Israel I dare
you I dare you to Christian Israel you
know what would happen to you yeah you
know what would have happened to you if
you can't talk be quiet let the ones who
can talk talk let them do it I heard you
attacked brother Eamon for whatever
reason
what do you think of brother amen
how can he be a brother and an akhi at
the same time I don't understand like he
his name his first name is
uh see I'll give you a general rule
you're going to find a lot of people
that are just popping up randomly and
giving Darwa
and this is very problematic okay it's
very problematic because you need to do
research not anybody and everybody who
talks about religion is is legit and you
can take a religion from him
be quiet be quiet yeah
okay for the sake of Allah be quiet
enough of your fitna enough
yeah you've got white beard have some
shame have some shame
you are at every opportunity looking for
the fault of others man say Allah what
kind of individuals are you and your
principles we don't you know don't sit
with innovates Etc
Hussain to be an innovator to your
standards by the way to your standards
not that we believe them
to your standards but you sit down with
them one rule for another another rule
for you the point is separate that's a
different issue the point I'm saying is
this this has done a video saying oh you
know he has a friend that has been 14
times stabbed or for every step should I
do a video or should I do a reminder Etc
whatever
I know he's not mocking Eamon he's
talking about his friend who's there
who's laughing or whatever for that
matter but the point is this
still in that talk you're talking about
Eamon why are you talking about him
the prophet sallam said the Muslim is
the one who his his hand and his tongue
is free from harming the other Muslims
so my brother and I'm telling the people
are watching this go and listen to amen
he's doing a greater service to the
ummah than these guys can ever do sadly
because all these brothers do is back by
tostand individuals I'm so sorry clearly
so brother amen he at least serves Uma
and sadly this Prophet I don't want to
mention
is saying that you know he mentions that
makes a clarification that apparently
you know that 14 times Staffing was an
amen yeah we know that was an amen but
in totality he was talking about Eamon
but then he says yeah our brother Eamon
was oppressed by these guys who stabbed
them
did the process tell us the one who
backed by his brother is like he is his
flesh you're seeing that they oppressed
him by stabbing him okay you are
President
you are oppressing the guy by back Parts
it means not even done a video saying
that you have his number
you call and spoke to him and now you do
a public video and the same thing
happened to me with this boxed about
this guy who actually backstabbed me
Sajid backstab above waiting for my
video to slip up do something with an
enemy of Islam who's ripping the Quran
and they go and insult me call me an
imbecile and they go and defend this guy
and Dave Dr David would talk to David
with they were saying Dr David wood you
can't make this stuff up
and amen I know exactly how you feel he
calls you one minute on the phone he's
got a number
the moment you don't agree with him
brother you're dropped same thing
happened the guy has my number they
don't call you know why because Brava
like even Tamia said sadly and I'm not
trying to be harsh on this problem I'm
being real some people are like flies
they don't see any good in anybody all
they do is land on bad places
because for me to someone to attack amen
because of him speaking like a roadman
or mention a story is crazy we have a
basic principle it's time of the lesser
of the two evils we can't even say this
is an evil yeah speaking like a roadman
and mentioned a story actually carry on
Amen carry on you have our full support
as your brother brother just carry on
doing what you're doing you are doing a
great service to the ummah alhamdulillah
may Allah protect you preserve you carry
on actually and ignore these individuals
whoever there for that matter what Allah
ignore them if you do not follow their
man Hajj you're finished alhamdulillah
soon there's a long video coming out
exposing them fully inshallah not by us
but that's what I wanted to say brother
says inshallah may Allah preserve and as
Muslims we should defend the honor of
other believers and my job here is that
I have nothing personal against his
other brothers I'm here to defend the
owner of these guys of amen and whoever
it is for that matter anyone who knows
me I've been doing this from day dot and
I will do it and inshallah that at least
it might be a mean I enter General that
I tried my best to defend the owner of a
Believer rather than harming with my
hand or my tongue
until next time
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about Islam every youngster
that memorized the Quran all of this and
so much more can be only a scale of Good
Deeds click the link and donate what you
can and share the video for even extra
reward